buenas noches las una se van a cerrar en
la provincia de ontario y québec a las
nueve y media de la noche y hacia las
siete de la noche hora del pacífico se
cerrarán las urnas en la provincia de
colombia británica se espera una jornada
bastante larga bastante una noche
bastante larga de los candidatos del
partido liberal yo sin trudeau y del
partido conservador su más
cercano oponente del primer ministro las
elecciones son unas elecciones atípicas
y nunca se había visto una en unas
elecciones tan reñidas como ésta y la
verdad pues el gobierno del primer
ministro george team trudeau espera
ganar las elecciones la oficina de
elecciones canadá también confirmó que
ya 5 millones 800 mil canadienses
ejercieron su derecho al voto recordemos
que son 27 millones los canadienses que
pueden votar en el país también vemos
qué
el partido liberal y el partido
conservador según la encuesta hecha
recientemente por civiles la cadena
estatal muestra un pequeño margen de
error entre los dos candidatos con
solamente una diferencia del punto cinco
por ciento
cristian que está en juego para el
candidato y primer ministro yo estoy
todo
bueno no solamente para el primer
ministro yo si todo está en juego su
permanencia en el poder como primer
ministro sino también está en juego en
la estrategia política que hizo al
lanzar unas elecciones a llamaron a las
elecciones anticipadas y prever que iba
a ganar y que iba a quedar como un
gobierno mayoritario
esta es una unas elecciones que son muy
criticadas por no solamente por el
partido conservador sino los otros
partidos de la oposición que han dicho
que el plan del primer ministro no fue
bien acogido porque fue en un momento de
una situación económica bastante difícil
que atraviesa el país yo sin trudeau
pues espera ganar las elecciones con una
mayoría absoluta para poder aprobar su
plan de relanzamiento económico entonces
el primer ministro definitivamente
necesita reportar estas elecciones ganar
estas elecciones para poder ejercer como
primer ministro con una ventaja bastante
bastante grande con respecto a su a su
oponente en el partido conservador